[Musik]
nachrichten des tages heute messbar
halver
guten abend schön dass sie dabei sind
wie auch norbert lehmann für den sport
alonso von mir und das sind einige der
themen von heute
kein lockdown mehr keine
schulschließungen spd grüne und fdp
wollen den bundesweiten corona notstand
beenden und den ländern dafür mehr
kompetenzen geben
der neue chef in düsseldorf hendrik wüst
übernimmt in nordrhein-westfalen den
posten des ministerpräsidenten von armin
laschet
viel munition wenig
sicherheitsvorkehrungen nach dem
tödlichen unfall an einem hollywood set
gerät die produktionsfirma in ein
schlechtes licht
heute ging es richtig los mit den
koalitionsverhandlungen spd grüne und
fdp tagen mit fast 300 leuten in 22
arbeitsgruppen noch regieren sie nicht
eines haben sie trotzdem schon
entschieden die korona ausnahme lage
soll am 25 november auslaufen und das
obwohl die neuinfektionen deutlich
steigen
23.000 212 neue fälle wurden innerhalb
von 24 stunden gemeldet die inzidenz
stieg von 113 auf 118 allerdings geht
auch das impfen weiter voran
66,4 prozent aller menschen in
deutschland sind laut rk ii doppelt
geimpft für spd grüne und fdp grund
genug die sogenannte epidemische lage zu
beenden ein ende der schutzmaßnahmen
bedeutet das nicht aus berlin britta
spiekermann
noch nicht als regierung im amt machen
die parlamentarier der ampel schon jetzt
konkrete politik der ausnahmezustand die
epidemische lage nationaler tragweite
soll kein dauerzustand sein und ende
november auslaufen dank im fortschritt
sei die gefahr für die bevölkerung nicht
mehr so groß somit erhebliche
beschränkung nicht mehr zu rechtfertigen
der 25 das sage ich auch wird aber kein
freedom day sein wir wollen
verantwortungsvoll durch den herbst und
den winter gehen damit wir quitt 19 im
frühling hinter uns haben generelle
schulschließungen ausgangssperren lockt
downs soll es künftig nicht mehr geben
wir legen den bundesländern
menschen kasten auf den tisch so dass
sie je nach infektionsgeschehen auch
handeln können aber keine tiefen
eingriffe in grundrechte
die länder sollen weiter auf bestimmte
maßnahmen zurückgreifen können wie die
masken pflicht 3g regelungen hygiene
konzepte in betrieben bei
veranstaltungen viele länder chefinnen
und chefs hatten angesichts steigender
infektionszahlen gegen das auslaufen der
epidemischen lage protestiert wenn es
aber keine mehrheit mehr gibt für diese
notlagen regelung die irgendwann ja
tatsächlich auch auslaufen muss ist dann
aber das mindeste dass wir brauchen eine
übergangsregelung märz 2022 sollen dann
alle beschränkungen wegfallen der
normalzustand zumindest rechtlich
wiederhergestellt sein das ist glaube
ich ein gutes zeichen für die demokratie
und sicherlich auch ein beitrag um das
vertrauen der bürgerinnen und bürger in
die politik zurückzugewinnen kanzlerin
merkel noch geschäftsführend im amt ließ
heute mitteilen sie sehe die aktuelle
entwicklung der pandemie mit sorge
der take all in berlin die entscheidung
zur pandemie notlage ist das eine was es
sonst vor den potenziellen
koalitionspartnern zu hören man hört so
etwas wie lauter werden das schweigen
jedenfalls dringen aus der stille der
verhandlung jetzt erste knirsch
geräusche heraus der generalsekretär der
fdp wissen beispielsweise hat sich zu
wort gemeldet und grüne und spd davor
gewarnt wieder in den wahlkampf modus
zurückzufallen scholz und habeck hatten
ja den liberalen vorgeworfen mit ihrem
nein zu steuererhöhungen eine entlastung
unterer einkommensgruppen zu verhindern
die frage der finanzen dürfte insgesamt
der härteste brocken in den
verhandlungen sein denn es geht schlicht
um nicht zu vereinbaren dass eine
eingehaltene schuldenbremse stabile
steuern und gleichzeitig hunderte
milliarden für zusätzliche investitionen
bereitzustellen und am ende dürfte man
sich auch um posten streiten die fdp hat
heute schon mal klar gemacht dass sie
eine quotenvorgabe fürs kabinett ablehnt
dankeschön für diese information live
aus berlin theo koll
nordrhein westfalen hat einen neuen
ministerpräsidenten
der 46 jährige cdu mann hendrik wüst
wurde zum nachfolger von armin laschet
gewählt der bleibt in berlin als
einfacher abgeordneter im bundestag
überraschend war dass wüst mindestens
drei stimmen aus der opposition kam aus
düsseldorf dominik müller russ l von den
gültigen stimmen stimmten mit ja 103
die erleichterung riesig es hat also
geklappt bereits im ersten wahlgang
trotz nur hauchdünne mehrheit von cdu
und fdp der neue ministerpräsident
henrik wüst dankbar kann nun ganz nach
vorn blicken auf all die themen und
herausforderungen die da auf ihn warten
große aufgaben liegen vor uns die
bewältigung der pandemie der
wiederaufbau nach der flut
wirtschaftliche stärke und innovation
digitalisierung steigende preise
bildungschancen und bezahlbarer wohnraum
und natürlich die bewahrung unserer
schöpfung der klimaschutz als größte
aufgabe unserer zeit
forsch immer wieder aneckt beginnt in
buchs karriere in der landespolitik
2006 generalsekretär der nrw cdu tritt
er nach vier jahren von diesem amt
zurück nach einer affäre um
gesprächstermine gegen bezahlung mit dem
damaligen ministerpräsidenten jürgen
rüttgers
2017 nimmt büßt karriere wieder fahrt
auf als verkehrsminister von nrw im
kabinett laschet bereits seit längerem
galt wüst als laschets kronprinz einen
neuen anfang will die opposition deshalb
auch nicht erkennen ich freue mich dass
die cdu jetzt ihre personalfrage endlich
geklärt hat jetzt geht es darum über die
inhalte zu diskutieren und zu streiten
nordrhein westfalen braucht viel mehr
als diese alte landesregierung bislang
abgeliefert hat und dafür werden wir
jetzt
denn in einem guten halben jahr stehen
landtagswahlen an in nrw und den landes
umfragen liegt die cdu deutlich hinter
der spd löst amtszeit könnte sehr kurz
wir
der erhoffte deutliche wirtschaftliche
aufschwung nach der korona krise kommt
aber er kommt mit verspätung das war
heute die botschaft von
wirtschaftsminister altmaier noch im
april war die bundesregierung von einem
wachstum von 3,5 prozent für dieses jahr
ausgegangen nun rechnet sehen nur noch
mit 2,6 prozent deutlich besser soll es
dagegen nächstes jahr laufen mit einem
plus von 4,1 prozent
ein grund für die verzögerung die
weltweiten lieferengpässe sind klasse
berichtet immer häufiger stehen die
ampeln auf rot stehen einzelne maschinen
still
präzisionswerkzeuge unter anderem für
die autoindustrie stellen sie her baum
in tübingen doch weil die autoproduktion
durch lieferengpässe etwa bei
halbleiterchips massiv eingebremst wird
brechen hier nun aufträge weg wir sind
nicht in der kurzarbeit wir sind aber
vorsichtig und sagen wenn das so
weitergeht und die signale negativer
werden müssen wir reagieren die
historisch beispiellosen produktions und
lieferengpässe bei halbleitern und
verschiedenen rohstoffen auch durch die
weltweiten folgen der pandemie dazu
gestiegene energiepreise sie setzen vor
allem der industrie zu bremsen die
wirtschaftliche erholung noch
wirtschaftsminister altmaier muss die
wachstumsprognose heute daher deutlich
nach unten korrigieren zumindest für
dieses jahr
wir gehen aber davon aus das ist die
gute nachricht ist dass wachstum nicht
weg fällt sondern sich lediglich in das
nächste jahr verschiebt wenn wir gehen
davon aus dass ein teil der probleme
behoben sein wird diesen optimismus
teilen auch viele experten wenngleich
durch die pandemie und ihre folgen
rückschläge auch weiter nicht
ausgeschlossen sind die chancen stehen
sehr gut dass die deutsche wirtschaft
anfang 2022 wieder das vorkrisen niveau
hat aber zur ehrlichkeit gehört auch
dazu die unsicherheit ist enorm das
heißt es könnte auch im kommenden jahr
holprig werden für manche branchen in
deutschland darauf müssen wir uns
einstellen dennoch der aufschwung
insgesamt dürfte anhalten auch wenn es
langsamer vorangeht als ursprünglich
erhofft
der streit zwischen der eu und polen
spitzt sich weiter zu jetzt hat der
europäische gerichtshof ein zwangsgeld
gegen das land verhängt warschau soll
täglich eine million euro an die eben
kommission zahlen weil sich die
regierung von ministerpräsident morawetz
geweigert die 2018 geschaffene
disziplinarkammer des obersten gerichts
aufzulösen viele eu-staaten und
kommissionspräsidentin von der leyen
werfen polen vor mit dieser reform die
unabhängigkeit der justiz auszuhöhlen
fragen wir unsere neben korrespondenten
florieren neuhann glaubt brüssel
wirklich dass dieses zwangsgeld polen
zum einlenken bringt
viele sehen wir tatsächlich im
finanziellen sanktionen die letzten und
vielleicht die einzige chance die
polnische regierung von ihrem kurs
abzubringen es geht ja nicht um dieses
zwangsgeld von heute sondern auch um die
korona milliarden aus dem aufbau paket
die aus demselben grund seit monaten
nicht an polen ausgezahlt werden und
insofern gab es heute viele positive
rückmeldungen zu diesem urteil aus dem
europaparlament von spd cdu grünen oder
fdp aber die ersten reaktionen aus
warschau klang nicht so als würde die
polnische regierung da jetzt schnell ein
lenkt im gegenteil man sprach von
erpressung durch den europäischen
gerichtshof
insofern keine der beiden seiten will
hier einen pol exit also einen austritt
polenz aus der europäischen union und
trotzdem hat man das gefühl da rasen
gerade zwei züge aufeinander zu und ein
ausweichmanöver ist zumindest bis jetzt
nicht zu bemerken die einschätzung aus
brüssel von florian leu hand vielen dank
kinder unter zwölf jahren gegen korona
impfen in deutschland ist dafür bislang
kein wirkstoff zugelassen
die usa dagegen stehen kurz davor ein
expertengremium im fall die notfall
zulassung für den impfstoff von biotec
weiser für fünf bis elfjährige
üblicherweise folgt die
arzneimittelbehörde fti den beratern
eine impfkampagne für die etwa 28
millionen betroffenen kinder könnte
schon im november starten
schon länger drängen die usa die briten
den wikileaks gründer julien assange
auszuliefern ab heute entscheidet
darüber ein berufungsverfahren in london
vor dem gerichtsgebäude forderten
anhänger seine freilassung noch im
januar hatte eine richterin die
auslieferung assange abgelehnt zu
angeschlagen seine gesundheit zu
fragwürdig die haftbedingungen in den
usa hieß es damals die amerikaner sehen
in assange einen vertreter von militär
geheimnissen ihm droht lebenslange haft
wer oder was ist schuld am tod von
halyna hudgens die
42-jährige kamerafrau war vor sechs
tagen beim dreh eines westerns in santa
fe erschossen worden offenbar
versehentlich von hauptdarsteller alec
baldwin eine tragödie die nicht nur
hollywood auffüllt viele fragen sind
offen erste antworten haben ermittler
vor einer stunde gegeben benjamin daniel
berichtet
wir brauchen dringend hilfe sind die
worte von menschen zu hören auf der
veröffentlichten aufnahme des notrufs
die mitarbeiterin beim dreh hatte
unmittelbar nach dem tödlichen unfall
die polizei alarmiert die beamten
ermitteln seit dem in viele richtungen
die aufmerksamkeit richtet sich vor
allem auf jene die für die sicherheit
der waffen am set verantwortlich waren
die erst 24-jährige waffen meisterin
sowie den regieassistenten der schon
einmal wegen eines waffen unfalls am set
schlagzeilen machte vor gut einer stunde
gaben der zuständige sheriff und die
bezirksstaatsanwältin ihre erste
pressekonferenz
wir haben insgesamt 500 schuss munition
sicherstellen können eine mischung aus
platzpatronen requisiten munition und
wie wir glauben auch scharfer munition
warum war echte munition am set wie
konnte sie in die film waffe gelangen
wer trägt die schuld noch sind viele
fragen unbeantwortet
auch ob alec baldwin gegebenenfalls eine
mitschuld vorgeworfen werden könnte im
moment ist alles noch völlig offen ich
kommentiere daher nicht ob es
strafverfolgung geben wird und gegen wen
wir können diese fragen nicht
beantworten bevor wir mit unseren
untersuchungen weiter gekommen sind
ein western dreh der als tragödie endet
es bleibt das gedenken an die getötete
kamerafrau berliner hutchins
auch zdf heute life widmet sich dem
thema dort können wir unter anderem
einem waffenmeister fragen stellen der
bei vielen filmen mitgearbeitet hat
gleich um halb acht in der zdf- heute-
app und auf unseren social media kanälen
kaum ein deutscher künstler wird in
frankreich so gefeiert wie georg
baselitz
der maler und bildhauer aus sachsen ist
berühmt für seine expressiven
figurativen werke die er gerne auf den
kopf stellt als einer von ganz wenigen
deutschen wurde er heute in paris in die
akademie der schönen künste aufgenommen
ganz in der nähe zeigt besondere
pompidou in einer ausstellung wie der
83-jährige zum weltstar wurde christel
haus
zero dom lehrer dumm heißt dieses werk
direkt vor der akademie deba es ist
eigens für seinen schöpfer dort
aufgestellt worden georg baselitz der
ist hier seit heute mit degen und orden
mitglied auf lebenszeit nicht ohne grund
paris hat baselitz geprägt
so eine komplette
kunstvolle stadt mit unglaublichen
kulturen ich habe eigentlich dieses
paris benutzt wie meine quelle gewürdigt
wird der künstler der zeit auch anderswo
in paris das sontra pompidou widmet ihm
eine große retrospektive
da sind der junge der an hitler erinnert
mit seinem riesigen penis damals ein
skandal helden die keine sind skulpturen
wie geschunden all die werke die ein
künstler mit wut im bauch erschafft wut
über die dramen der deutschen geschichte
die er erlebt hat und
er hat die kunst auf den kopf gestellt
die stärke der werke überträgt sich und
auch die kopf stehenden bilder sind gut
unsere welt steht doch auch kopf
er lebte den mauerbau den kalten krieg
den mauerfall all das ist in seinen
bildern
ein politischer künstler wollte baselitz
nie sein doch ohne geschichte ohne ein
bisschen provokation kann er auch nicht
heftiger allerdings gibt auch eine große
distanz dass dieses europa wütend sein
verschwindet jetzt hat georg baselitz
seinen sitz im französischen olymp der
schönen künste weil er immer seinen
eigenen weg gegangen ist
starke niederschläge haben auf der
mittelmeerinsel sizilien schwere schäden
angerichtet besonders betroffen ist der
osten der insel weiter teile der stadt
catania wurden überflutet ein mann starb
als er von den wassermassen unter sein
auto gedrückt wurde und ab morgen drohen
möglicherweise noch schwerere unwetter
schulen und die meisten geschäfte
bleiben geschlossen
jetzt fußball neue zweite runde im dfb
pokal ja keine wirklich großen
überraschungen gestern abend aber
erstligist freiburg der schrammte
haarscharf an einer blamage vorbei gegen
drittligist osnabrück ein
atemberaubendes achterbahn spielen mit
verlängerung und elfmeterschießen
es ist ersatz torhüter benito der zum
freiburger helden wird beim 3 2 im
elfmeterschießen
vorteil für die playboy villa so brutal
trainiert immer und ja es nicht aus
sicht der hat immer zuspiele wechseln
die verzweiflung der trainer spät die
tore osnabrück schaffte es mit dem 1 1
von botanik gerade so in die
verlängerung siebten minute der
nachspielzeit
freiburg schafft es mit dem 2 2 von
kevin schlotterbeck gerade so ins
elfmeterschießen in dem opa drei der
osnabrücker elfmeter pariert freiburg
erstmals seit vier jahren wieder im
achtelfinale gerade so
und heute abend im dfb pokal unter
anderem das top spiel gladbach gegen
münchen die bayern mit lukas egon dames
der nun doch nicht morgen in spanien
eine haftstrafe antreten muss
stattdessen eine bewährungs und
geldstrafe wegen eines beziehungsstreits
mit seiner heutigen ehefrau ja und in
genau 100 tagen beginnen die olympischen
winterspiele in peking die größte
herausforderung für die organisatoren in
china der schutz vor dem corona virus
auf den wichtigsten tv kanälen des
chinesischen staatsfernsehens läuft die
show der olympics bevor sie in 100 tagen
wirklich beginnt und der ioc-präsident
schickt auch bei gross
wir können wirklich sagen zusammen in
eine gemeinsame zukunft und diese
gemeinsame zukunft wird eine leuchtende
für die winterspiele weltweit doch die
realität in china ist komplizierter als
das olympische komitee es glauben machen
möchte stichwort corona ungeimpfte
athleten können nicht einreisen oder
müssen 21 tage in quarantäne
wer die krone regeln bricht riskiert
gesperrt zu werden stichwort
menschenrechte die unterdrückung von
minderheiten wie in django der tibet
china will asbeck vision das olympische
komitee will es nicht thematisieren
das was am sport dankeschön zum schluss
noch ein vehikel das wohl selbst james
bond neidisch machen würde ein hofer
bike eine mischung aus motorrad und
führt mobil japanische tüftler haben es
jetzt zur serienreife entwickelt
verschlafe 680.000 us dollar lässt sich
damit jedem stau ein schnippchen
schlagen in fünf metern höhe und mit bis
zu 100 kilometer pro stunde
klitzekleiner nachteil noch hat das one
dabei keine zulassung
hier kommt möglicherweise eine
hilfreiche finanzspritze die lottozahlen
sie lauten 16 16 20 21 25 45 superzahl 6
weitere gewinnzahlen finden sie auf
lotto punkt zdf.de und im zdf text auf
seite 5 157
manchmal kann auch das wetter wie ein
sechser im lotto sein morgen im süden
oft neblig sonst viel sonne die details
hat gleich katja oliver das heute
journal mit bettina schausten um viertel
vor zehn danke für ihr interesse machen
sie sich noch einen schönen abend und
bis morgen wenn sie mögen
[Musik]
guten abend im nebel blieb bis heute
richtig kühl da lagen die
höchsttemperaturen hier an der donau nur
bei neun grad mit sonnenschein und wenn
die wolken auf rissen und bei südwind
kletterten sie dagegen bis 18 grad in
norddeutschland waren die wolken etwas
dichter und bleiben es auch jetzt in der
nacht sonst ist es häufig klar und hier
im süden bildet sich erneut nebel die
temperaturen sinken in bayern und in
baden württemberg zum teil auf plus 3
bis minus 1 grad da droht also überall
bodenfrost sonst bleibt die nacht bei 10
bis 4 grad milder und morgen erwarten
uns dann höchsttemperaturen hier
zwischen dem sauerland und eifel und
ober und niederbayern so von 8 bis 14
grad am alpenrand am oberrhein und vor
allen dingen in norddeutschland wird es
bei 15 bis 18 grad ungewöhnlich mild für
ende oktober
das liegt daran dass die sonne wirklich
strahlen scheinen kann allerdings stören
auch einige nebelfelder die werden sich
wohl nicht überall auflösen zum beispiel
an der donau da könnte es knapp werden
mit der nebelauflösung mit diesem wetter
geht es am freitag auch gleich weiter
danach allerdings wird es zum wochenende
von westen etwas unbeständiger an den
temperaturen ändert sich vorerst wenig
schön ab noch